joining me now is christina bob attorney
for president trump who was on site for
that raid christina thank you for
joining us tonight
um does president trump support
or oppose the release of the affidavit
president trump has been very
straightforward and that he supports all
transparency through this process and he
wants what's best for the american
people and he's going to rely on the
courts to do the right thing
so he will not then submit or you will
not submit a motion to the court to
release the affidavit in opposition to
what the government said today
uh we're we support what judicial watch
has
started we're watching it very closely
trying to to gauge what's happening and
we'll respond accordingly so i don't
have an exact answer today we're
watching the situation and seeing how it
develops and will respond in a way that
we think is best for the american people
so no determine on no determination on
that as of now because that that is the
most crucial piece of information
because that document apparently
establishes they they say probable cause
it includes sensitive information the
government's arguing uh they don't want
to compromise uh i guess
uh cooperating witnesses and it's there
so far it's their case against
president trump
such that it is
right you're exactly right and
supposedly it does have probable cause
in it i find that
a little bit hard to believe obviously a
judge signed it but knowing the
background in the situation i don't
think there is probable cause to do what
they did so uh i am myself curious to
see what's in it and we're we're looking
forward to seeing how this all plays out
but you're not i mean i mean
i don't know given given the president's
comments earlier we would think that he
would want it all out out there so
everyone can see it in the light of day
i'm still not following what would the
concern be
on your part for not having it released
no we are we are supporting it we're not
i'm not aware of any
effort to oppose it we just are
following the lead of the case that's
already going and watching to see what
happens in response to it but okay
absolutely
yeah fair so he's he's not opposing its
release but he's not going to urge that
it be released is that a correct
characterization i think i would say
that's a fair assessment at this point
yes okay
on the issue of the passports which
to me is just another ridiculous wrinkle
here um earlier today the president said
um that the fbi stole his three
passports one expired
um that it's an assault on a political
opponent at a level never seen before in
our country and apparently you told our
producers just before the show that the
passports have now been picked up so you
got them back uh two expired ones the
diplomatic passport that every former
president gets to keep in his possession
what's your view on this was just this
was just an honest mistake was it were
they in advance i don't know about any
honest i won't give them that much
credit at this point i think this goes
to show the level of
audacity that they have if you're gonna
execute a raid on the primary residence
of the president of the united states
you need to do it perfectly there's no
room for error and when our fourth
amendment rights are at stake as a
nation you cannot be flippant in any way
so i i don't give them a pass as this
was a simple mistake i think it goes to
show how aggressive they were how
overreaching they were that they were
willing to go past the four corners of
the warrant and take whatever
they felt was appropriate or they felt
that they could take and then go back
through and look through everything and
once they realized oh whoops maybe we
went a little too far then negotiate the
return of it and that's absolutely not
the way a warrant is supposed to be
executed so no i think they were wrong
and basically got caught
where where were the passports uh were
they in a safe were they in a drawer a
box i mean where were they
i don't actually know they were probably
in the office i would assume because
that makes the most sense but
again they didn't disclose where they
picked things up so i can't say for
certain now in his first interview since
the raid the president told fox news
digital that people are so angry at what
is taking place whatever we can do to
help the temperature has to be brought
down in the country if it isn't terrible
things are going to happen
what did the president mean by terrible
things are going to happen
i think he just is looking at what's
happening in the country and realizing
the angst that people are going through
i think he's saddened by the frustration
that americans are facing in realizing
that their government has been hijacked
by
radicals radicals that don't care about
the american people and don't care about
our quality of life and our culture as a
culture this is a new step that we've
never experienced before and a level to
some extent of fear in the nation that
the government's becoming overreaching
and i think i think he's concerned about
that devolution of our culture and what
we hold sacred that is what i believe i
didn't specifically ask him that
question but that would be my
understanding that he doesn't like the
direction that the country's going well
of course the left is jumping on it
saying the president's intimating that
people could commit violence be another
january 6th
but you're saying that that's not what
you
you believe he was getting it was a
corrosive effect on that
correct not not at all president trump
loves this country and he's never
supported violence although the left has
so i think it's a bit hypocritical and
ironic that they would try to throw that
narrative out when he has been peaceful
and brought peace to the world and peace
to this nation uh and is trying to bring
peace to this nation he reached out to
merrick garland and said you know
anything i can do after you raided my
personal residence you know sorry this
is through his attorneys but he wanted a
specific message to merrick garland this
was not them directly but saying i want
merrick garland to know that i support
uh bringing this nation together and
lowering the temperature as you said
what can i do you know my resources are
at your disposal i'm willing to do
anything and the doj ignored it they
they didn't respond that was on thursday
morning and then a few hours later
merrick garland gave a three-minute
press brief where he didn't even bother
to disclose to the american public that
president trump was trying to be helpful
in the situation well what what
specifically was president trump
suggesting it's i mean everyone wants to
bring the temperature down i think
that's a noble you know desire of course
but what specifically
does he propose that he
can do at this point sure well i think
he was looking at it saying the american
people don't trust the fbi or doj they
lied about russia russia russia they
lied about crossfire hurricane they lied
to
congress comey lied to congress mccabe
lied to everybody they lied to the fisa
court the american people rightfully
don't trust the fbi right now and don't
trust the department of justice but they
do trust president trump and he has a
big platform he has a big following and
so i think it was a genuine olive branch
to say i'm trying to help this country
they don't trust you but they trust me
what can we do and they ignored it
well i mean short of dropping the cake
dropping the case i'm not sure
what merrick garland would do at this
point i mean you know right just drop
you know let's move on i mean i don't
know what the justice department's going
to do they're not they're not in favor
of releasing the affidavit we know that
all right but i i think it would go a
long way to just show that they care
that they are putting this nation
through angst the american people are
frustrated and angry they love donald
trump and no one believes that this is a
real a real case they believe it's a
witch hunt and so any attempt to come
together i think is fair um christina we
really appreciate your joining us
tonight thank you very much hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else